the fact that we now understand how
important it is for caregivers to be
connected and that we now have the
toolkit necessary to do that a few years
ago you couldn't connect anyone because
there were no linkages internet didn't
exist the ability of information to flow
freely didn't exist and I think right
now there's a sense that if you do the
right job for patients with
comorbidities you can seriously make
their lives better and there's a toolkit
that exists to do that and I think it's
very exciting that the other thing that
I'm really excited about is the fact
that medical science is going to get a
lot better with data and we now know
that patients who had a certain type of
belly fat 25 years ago are more likely
to have Alzheimer's we know that sir
cholesterol levels have a long-term
impact of Alzheimer's we know who their
whole series of things that we now know
from looking at databases that we could
not have possibly known before we had
the longitudinal database and we're
going to be taking DNA and we're going
to have one of our projects is going to
have DNA on about 500,000 people so it's
going to be a huge database we're going
to tie the DNA database to electronic
medical record and we're going to start
looking for correlations and we're going
to discover things and we're going to
learn we're going to learn things right
now that we don't even suspect there's
going to be learning it's going to come
out of that I think it's going to be
extremely powerful and when that happens
then we can start focusing optimal care
on patients in a very important way so
that gives me great confidence in and is
very exciting and I think we're very
close to a golden age we're very close
to a medical science golden age that is
only empowered by data most medical
research projects right now have 200
patients 300 patients they run for three
years and they stop if you look at the
kind of medical research that's out
there it's tiny samples for short
timeframes and we're going to have the
ability to do massive samples an
extended time frames and figure things
out that you can't figure out without
that
so that's right